Okay, the answer should be 1. Here's how we figure that out. I know as I go from
27 to 9, I divide by 3, and then to get to 9 to 3, I divide by another 3. So to
find 3 to the zero, I need to take my number and divide it again by 3, 3 divided
by 3 makes 1. That's how I know 3 to the zero is 1. It turns out that this is
true for any power of zero. Okay, I've re-drawn my pattern of 2. I know as the
exponent decreases, this number also decreases. To get from 8 to 4, I divided by
2. This should make sense because I know exponents represent repeated
multiplication. So to drop one exponent, I need to undo multiplication I need to
do Division.
And then to get from 42, I divide by 2 again. So, I know to get from 2, 2 to the
0, I have to divide by 2 one more time. I have to drop my exponent one. I have
to undo multiplication, so I do division, and I get one.